I think folks, we're gonna go ahead and get started. Uh,
hi, everyone. Um, thank you all for attending the talks
today. My name's Corey Dobson. Uh, I'm a
solution engineering lead here at Poolside.
Uh, today I'm gonna be joined by Ivo, uh, principal,
uh, principal from our solutions architecture
team, and, uh, Praveen, a senior
engineer, uh, from Northrop Grumman Space
Systems, an organization who actually deployed Poolside,
uh, securely in their organization.
Uh, I want to thank AWS for the opportunity to
speak today and for you all wrapping up, uh,
you know, the final day of the conference, spending the afternoon with us.
Uh, it's, it's really been great.
Uh, as this session is titled, uh, Poolside
AI Models for highly secure software
Environments, uh, we want to present today a high-level
overview of our product stack and
how it's unique for software teams either in,
uh, those highly controlled or,
um, air gapped, uh, scenarios.
Uh, and kind of an overview of our deployment
structure, what that looks like on AWS as well.
Uh, poolside's models are built for various types of users.
Uh, however, software is, is really a bread and butter
kind of use case for us. So
we're gonna also show some demos of this stack
working within the SDLC,
uh, and hear how
software folks like Praveen,
uh, at, at Northrop are using Poolside
today. Uh, if you like what you hear in the presentation,
we do have a booth in the expo hall. I know the expo's,
uh, closing soon, but it's a booth number,
um, 802. It's right, uh, big parasol
booth when you walk in. So
some of, some folks are head nodding, you might have visited the booth
and grabbed some poolside swag
throughout the week, but maybe after this session,
hop over there and,
uh, come and visit us, especially if you think poolside
might be able to help out, uh, your organization and your software
teams. Uh, so let's get, let's get started.
Uh, what is Poolside? Well, Poolside is a frontier
model lab building secure enterprise
AI systems,
uh, deployed anywhere.
Uh, we're a US based company, founded in 2023,
and we build both AI models and
the agent orchestration platform that powers
them, uh, completely from scratch, uh,
designed to run entirely within your own infrastructure.
Uh, AI has definitely reshaped how
even the most, you know, secure mission critical
work gets done.
Uh, and our aim at Poolside is to, uh, be
that, be that mission, uh, mission critical
platform. Uh, we power
teams with our complete AI infrastructure stack,
uh, and some expert research engineers to help
design their AI workloads.
Uh, we've read about far too many, uh, POCs
that never make it, uh, into the production
stage. They stay AI POCs,
um, either due to some data that needs
to, uh, stay within the network that unfortunately
has to keep getting passed out.
Uh, or teams just not being able to confidently deploy
AI agents at scale,
uh, within their infrastructure. So we solved this
with both the software stack, uh, and
research experts, um,
to embed with your team.
So let's dig into that software stack to start,
uh, and learn about what we mean when we say
complete AI infrastructure.
Uh, to start, it begins, uh, with the poolside
Foundational models. Uh, poolside models are trained
with internet scale data, and they're combined, combined
with some proprietary, uh, synthetic data sets
we have. Um, our colleague at Poolside, Joe
Roll, uh, did an excellent job earlier
today, uh, breaking this down in a previous talk.
Uh, so if you're interested in how we actually do
pre-training and post. Training of these AI models,
uh, and what we call our model factory, our model
building process, uh, I'd recommend checking out
the recording of that talk, uh, or
checking out our blog on our page, our
website, um, page called the Model Factory.
Uh, it's, it's quite a deep dive into this virtualization
environment, but it's what we scaled, uh, for
our applied research team, uh, to be able
to, to scale up model checkpoints and be able
to essentially build this, this piece here of our stack.
Uh, it's worth noting that this, uh, poolside model,
uh, uh, piece is, um,
not based on an open source model. It's not just
say, say it's
an open source model and then fine-tuned, but rather,
uh, our model that we run pre-training and post-training
on. Uh, and we have some novel techniques
built around reinforcement learning, which allow us to
create some high quality synthetic data sets,
uh, for future model training too. Uh,
so Poolside doesn't require nor, nor do
we want, uh, any of your data
for model training. Um,
when you use Poolside, no data comes back
to us to train the model. That's a, that's a core philosophy
of us. Uh, it's truly, you know,
your own model that you have on-prem. When you deploy
poolside, you get the model and all of the weights.
Uh, so, um, it's, it's
really the, the complete, complete stack here,
and it starts with, it starts with the models.
Uh, it leads us to the next piece, which is connecting
it to your organization's data and making it
relevant for your team.
Uh, since poolside's deployed entirely in your boundary,
uh, it can, it can be connected to any data source,
uh, securely because essentially we come
to where the data is. We don't ask
your data to come to us, but rather we bring
the stack to you. And this allows Poolside
to securely access context from knowledge bases
or runtime,
uh, data sources that you normally wouldn't
want to pass outside of your network. Well, you can, you
can pass those securely to Poolside without compromising
any of your intellectual property. So, unlike,
you know, maybe other AI models that send your
data outside of the network and and or into some
sort of data mode,
um, Poolside brings, you know, the stack,
stack to you.
We then meet developers and teams, you know, wherever they are
to access those models. So,
um, they can be accessed through a multitude of different IDEs.
We talked about software engineering use cases we're
gonna see this in just a minute, um,
as well as through
a terminal CLI, uh, encoding agents
for, for software engineers,
um, but it's Poolside's built for the whole
organization. So although, you know, we'll call out products
like our API and our IDE,
uh, and, uh, even non-developers will use Poolside
through our agent orchestration platform, and I'll show
a little bit of that, uh, here in, here in a demo,
uh. But, um,
the, the takeaway here is that we build really the back
end model structure and the front end interface
for your, for your team. So when you have poolside,
you have, in this case, the model infrastructure
and all the product interfaces.
This all again gets deployed in your
uh secured network. Now poolside's really truly
isolated AI
for your organization, and this enables us to work
with even the most highly regulated,
uh, you know, financial services companies, public
sector companies,
uh, they can leverage frontier AI tools
without, in this case,
uh, the risk of data egress or some sort of,
um, uh, uh, data leaving the network. It's,
it's a stack that they can deploy for
their entire organization.
And we can design this whole stack
to where maybe it's a single deployment of poolside or
multiple deployments of poolside for various different
programs. So even the most, you
know, mission critical um work can
can leverage a secure AI platform and
over time this uh this stack becomes a
uh an AI software foundation for you to build on because it's
all within your control again you have the model weights,
you have all the product interfaces, it all it's customized
for your security boundary,
um, and we don't have the, the risk of data egress,
you know, losing core IP for your business
so. We don't require or want
any of your data to, to make this stack better, we
give it to you and let you customize it.
Uh, we have two models available today in our stack.
Malibu Agent is our gente model. Uh, Point
is our, is our auto completion model for code,
uh, and they can be, uh, deployed
entirely within your organization's, uh, AWS
account, uh, either in an AWS
VPC,
uh, or Amazon Bedrock. Um, we
also can track entirely through your existing
AWS agreement.
So we have a fairly rare tier one agreement
with AWS,
allowing customers to use their existing AWS agreement
and, and, uh, committed spend,
uh, to use, to use Poolside.
Uh, so I'm gonna pass it over to Ivo, and I wanna dig
in, um, here for a few minutes on
how to deploy Poolside within an AWS account.
That Thank you. Not the mic.
Uh, cool.
So I think we saw a lot of slides that didn't show any
AWS thingish, right?
And you're also in AWS conference. So I wanna get you
started on what we actually deploy in your
environment, right?
As Coty said, this is completely
within your account. We don't have any SAS offering right
now, so we actually deploy this with you.
Uh, you, we help you deploy in, in your specific
account. Starting from the bottom, I'd like
to walk you through the diagram. So it's a very simple architecture
as you can see.
Uh, we have like a database, post squares. It's
an RDS,
uh, and then we can have the brains of the operation which
is our EKS cluster.
Uh, EKS cluster is where things start to get
interesting, right? So you'll see two node groups there. One is grayed
out, uh, because it's optional. So our
mandatory node group is like a CPO node group.
This is actually where our API runs,
web assistants, which is basically like a UI, right?
Uh, and then you have optional node group which is GPUs,
in this case P.
5s, uh, and it's optional because you can also
deploy on Bedrock,
and by deploy I mean you can use it, right?
You either choose to use, uh, your own GPUs
and we give you the wage for that, or you run
on Bedrock and you just call the API from, from
the CPU networks. Uh, you see like a
bunch of auxiliary services here too, right? You
see S3, you see CR,
uh, and the reason for that is because like we
have to host our, our things somewhere
to access it. Very simple. You just
access it through a load balancer. You see it is in a public subnet,
so you know it couldn't be a simpler architecture.
Uh, but some of our customers, as you'll
see with NGC and others,
are very secure focused.
Security
is a tier one construct for AWS as
well, and they told us, uh, we cannot have internet
access at all, so they cannot have an IGW on
their VPC.
Uh, and for us it is fine. We support it
too. If you look at this architecture, we basically
replaced the whole,
uh, public subnet with a private
one, and we created a bunch of
VPC endpoints.
For those not familiar with VPC endpoints, they're just a way
for you to access AWS services,
uh, without going through the internet.
So we still need obviously access to AWS
services and this is how we achieve it.
Uh, you also see that now the ALB became
a private ALB. You need to access this somehow.
Uh, we just changed it to, to a private one.
Uh, another security aspect from this
architecture, you'll see, I, I put some keys
around all the components
is that some customers can also not use AWS
managed keys. They're very useful to get started,
but not all customers can access those,
so they need to bring their own. This is very common
with security customers. Uh, and you see we
support you to bring your own keys. So from EKS
secrets, on the EBS notes, on the database,
so on and so forth.
Um, but when you look at this diagram,
if you are, you know, a little bit networking focused,
you'll see, OK, but how do I access this?
Like there's an ID extension, there's other components
like how am I gonna query this API if this is
an isolated VPC and everything is public.
Uh, and this is where the rest of the stock comes in,
right? So we are not picky. We
support all types of access,
for example, site to site VPN from your on-prem,
maybe client VPM from your employees'
computers,
Direct Connect, you name it. Like it doesn't matter for
us. We help you deploy this and make
sure it works, so we
kind of guide you to the deployment.
Uh, and you also see that I added the network
firewall there, and the reason I did is because we
also support,
uh, inspection architectures for this
specific slide. I put it as a centralized,
uh,
firewall which we believe this is on BBC. You go to transit gateway
and you are inspected. We also supported the architecture,
like, for example, distributed, uh, inspection.
So this is kind of like our architecture, as
you can see,
very simple. You'll be able to access it
from everywhere.
Uh, but for those of you that have been using
AWS more for more years, you know
that not all regions are created equally, right? So
it could be from service availability to
simply parts of the service availability.
Maybe sometimes the API is not available equally
everywhere, and this is not very, uh,
fun to find after the fact.
So we do support,
uh, many regions.
We kind of. Go with you and we basically check the
region you want to deploy to,
but even within the region, some are different,
and this, they call it partitions. For those not
familiar, in NWS partition is
something completely isolated that has regions
inside, uh, and they're only communicated through the
internet. So for example, you cannot use
uh an access key to communicate them, right?
Or any sort of TGW. This doesn't work.
Uh, we also support different partitions. You'll
see here the commercial one, Golf cloud,
uh, and we also support some that are not in the slide
like the secret region and the top secret region.
Again, I want to emphasize that we do help you deploy
this on these
partitions, right? And we kind of guide you
all the way.
Uh, I think you guys now
are a little bit familiar with how we deploy.
It's not super complex architecture.
Uh, I wanna also guide you through our customer
approach, right? If you deal with AWS, you
know that customer obsession is very important for
them. It's a leadership principle. They talk
about it on all the conferences,
uh, and I was AWS, so I'm very familiar with it.
Uh, at Poolside we can embrace it too,
right? So customers for us are
very, very important. Important and we wanted to
do right by them and we cannot just install
something and give them the keys and just leave.
The reason is that most AIPOCs right now
are failing, right? I think there's a statistic
from MIT says like something like 95%,
I think it is,
don't reach production, right?
So if I just give you the access to our model, no matter
how good our model is, no matter how good our agents are,
most likely you have like a 5% chance to make
this success, right?
And that's why we at Poolside guide you
all the way
to until you reach production.
Our SA and SCs help you become
what we like to call
agentic organization.
What does this mean? It's not just a keyword, I promise.
We help you
achieve your use cases by creating new agents,
maybe doing like some prompt engineering, but
actually what we try to own with you are
the actual business outcomes.
We do this in a more, I would say, consultative
approach,
and it's been working out for us,
but some specific clusters needed even more than
that. They needed like a boots on the
ground, hands on the keyboard approach,
uh, and that's why we created a 4
deployed
research engineering motion.
What are these guys?
Well, they are applied research engineers,
right? So they are not some typical
LinkedIn influencer that says
KV cash and gets a bunch of likes, OK?
So they are really people with experience
taking POCs to production in AI,
OK? Uh, and they help you
as an extension of your team.
So, they will work within your teams, within your
engineering,
product teams,
uh, and they will help you achieve your use
cases. This could be, you know, creating a new pipeline,
maybe creating a new agent, or maybe just
scaling this to thousands of users.
They are an extension of your team, really.
And by now I see your faces. So, if you
forget everything I said so far,
what I want you to take from this talk, OK,
is that poolside is not just about tokens,
OK? It's about business outcomes.
We are an enterprise-focused organization
and we help you.
Uh, have a shared responsibility model with
us, owning those outcomes.
So I don't just hand you the keys to the
model and say, you know, have fun,
uh, but we actually help you
get the best out of that.
Um, I, I'm engineering, as Corey said,
I'm a prisma engineer,
uh, and I'm not about just talk, so I wanna
show you real
demos,
uh, and for that I'll call Corey
that is gonna show you how all of this actually works.
Yeah, thank you so much, Iva.
Yeah, so let's dig into some of the use case demos
and uh this stack in action
with with the software focus, um,
uh, running with enterprise code.
Uh, the first demo here is a clear
case that we were able to help, uh, uh,
software teams with, especially teams that work in,
uh, legacy systems and or
closed environments.
Um, in this demo we're going to, uh,
show how the, uh, poolside. Uh,
ID extension and model, um,
converts a non-trivial ata code database
project into, into Rust.
Uh, what you'll see in the demo, I'll play it in just a sec,
uh, is, um,
the ID extension walking through this
code base,
understanding its structure
using tools, uh, and then rewriting
that, that, that structure.
Um, if anyone, I see a few
head nods or unfamiliar with AA code.
I was um before I started working with a few different
customers who use it. Ada code is a, a
legacy language.
Um, it was originally released in the early 80s.
It was uh developed by the US
Department of Defense and it's still used in very, in
many mission critical
applications in aerospace and aeronautics. So,
um,
uh, let's, let's get started and see, see this in action.
So I'll do my best to, to pause and narrate
here. What um you're seeing is,
is kind of the initial prompt to rewrite
this, this, uh, this codebase,
and uh you already see on the
left hand side there in the chat,
yeah, your, your right hand side.
Uh, there in the chat is, uh, the ability
for the, the agent and the model to start using tools,
right? So we're reading and grabbing through the code base.
Um, this is all poolside. It's important
to note that this is the poolside model, the poolside agent.
We are using an open source IDE as our
client here. Um, however, the ID extension
is also built by us, so the, the interfaces
are all poolside and the back end model is all poolside.
What you'll notice here as I play this, uh,
is that the inner monologue of the model also
creates this to do list and it breaks this down
much like how a senior software engineer would want to break this
down. We're rewriting a database, right? So
we need to think about the table structure, the record
structure, then we need to rewrite the query parser.
Um, each one of these steps
is potentially a new file, um,
potentially editing an existing file in the,
in the call chain, uh, and the agent
is kind of traversing here.
You also see it start to use different shell commands to
actually test its work as we get along.
Um, rewriting its, its implementation
as it might finds errors in its own code,
uh, and at the end of this demo we'll see
that we can actually go into the shell here after
we have a nice output of what it completed,
uh, and then test out some database commands,
and it's now a code to Rust, uh,
Rust style database.
So a single agent uh in the poolside
stack,
uh, running inside the IDE keep that in
mind, we're in the kind of the single agent process right
now. In
the next demo, uh, we're going to,
uh, work with um a multi-agent scenario, but
in this case we're gonna work in a in a headless fashion.
So imagine we're in the financial
services use case we have a,
a, a, a kind of demo stock trading app here,
uh, showing that, um, we might want to
traverse multiple issues that are
going wrong in our, in our program, um,
and. Uh, we're actually going to be using the
API and the agent runtime here with the
model, but outside of the IDE.
So in this case, we're going to be having
this AI enabled SDLC and the
agent model and uh interfaces
are going to be completing units of work
without necessarily the developer having to pull down
the code and um and initiate
that unit of work. So I'll go ahead and play
that in
um and narrate along the way.
So what you'll see is that we're using GitHub
issues here, just GitHub natives to track
uh issues with the project.
Um, and I'm gonna go ahead and pause that
because what we ended up doing is adding
a certain label to a GitHub
issue. Now, this label called the
pool set agent label is gonna fire off
a pool set agent runtime
that's then going to traverse into GitHub actions
and fire off a workflow.
There's a lot there, but if you were using, say,
Jira for project management and Jenkins
for your CICD, this exact flow
could be replicated.
We're the primitives here, in this case, the, the agent
runtime, uh, and the model. However,
we're just using
some pre-built tools to be able to show off, uh,
um,
a, uh, a workflow where we're going
to send off, uh, I believe,
4 to 3 or 4 agents all at once,
uh, to traverse 3 or 4 issues all at once. So
let me go ahead and play that again.
And we can walk through.
So we're adding the, the label to the
issues, we're, then we're going to
see the GitHub action workflows start
to uh fire off as well.
So you'll see that we have now, OK, 33,
workflows, uh,
in this case,
um, working, uh, simultaneously
as 3 kind of parallel agents,
all traversing different units of work, creating
the to do list, much like we saw in the IDE
demo. Um, and at the end of the
day, creating 3 pull requests that we can then
review. So this is a truly
like headless
AI enabled SDLC motion where
the, the code that you're seeing there in that pull request was
generated by the model, but it was generated by the agent
runtime that actually just ran in the GetUp actions
container,
um, full automation that we could lift
and shift, say different project management
or different CICD tools to be able to implement
in, say your organization's very secure
network. So the
first demo was single agent running in the IDE,
um, the second demo here, parallel agents
running in
a virtual machine in this case.
And the third demo is our agent orchestration
uh pipeline. So in this demo
we're going to have multiple agents chained together
as a, a, a longer pipeline,
and this pipeline is going to do some service investigation into
an EKS cluster that something is going wrong.
Imagine a new ticket comes through and
um where you need to diagnose kind of an infrastructure
service issue.
In this case, a user can't see their orders for
their account. Maybe that's a a
a a potential workflow, um, but
instead of, uh, manually traversing and
trying to figure out, OK,
which one of the order services or authentication
services or various services is inside of
the CKS cluster. Going wrong, we're going
to start an agentic pipeline and
fire off a multi-agent workflow chaining
the output of one agent to the next in this agent
orchestration platform. Again, all poolside
here, so the poolside agent runtime, the
poolside model, the poolside workflow,
um, getting to the point
where we can generate a report and say with, uh,
you know, in this case a high likelihood it's actually, you
know, this particular service that we need to go and,
and check out. So let's, let's play that and
see that in action.
So this is, in this case, the single agent workflow,
uh, and it's going to jump in
and and uh be able to discover the different
services that we have,
uh, and, and traverse this,
this longer pipeline. You'll see as well that
all of the agent trajectories and essentially
all the agent runs, we also can audit
here because we are both the back-end model
and the front end agent runtime.
Full traceability up and down the stack is,
is available with poolside.
If you're out there in the expo, you may see that there's,
um, there's companies that are built
purely around agent tracking, agent trajectories,
but poolside, we're, we're
able to do this because we, we're the full stack,
right? So, um, you kind of have, in
this case, a full stack solution to be able to build
these longer pipelines, um, and do
it securely with data sources that you may not
necessarily.
In this case, add to NAI pipeline,
uh, without something like Poolside.
And there's the end is kind of a nice report that
says, hey, this is what, what, what, what we need
to um uh traverse and figure
out kind of
uh where we need to go to figure out this issue, so.
Poolside sees a future where, you know, every enterprise
is going to want hundreds if not thousands of agents,
either in that single agent flow or
multiple agent pipelines, uh,
using various data sources. And from our perspective,
when we try to play this out 1824
months from now,
it makes. makes it even more crucial that
organizations, especially those in high consequence,
high secure environments and
organizations, um, own their stack, you know, secure
their infrastructure
around their AI platform, not letting the data leave the
network on Poolside, we really aim to be
that solution,
uh, and, uh, we're proud that
we've been able to be that solution for a variety of high
consequence organizations like NGC. So
I'm gonna pass it over to Praveen, uh, to hear on
their journey with Poolside.
Thanks, Corey.
So Northrop Grumman Space manages
uh mission critical systems,
and this is from uh
satellite constellation operations
to
multitude of other like on orbit
services, and these are assets,
not only high value assets but also
require really secure and hardened
systems all the way from the algorithmic
developments to deployments, testing
on the entire pipeline,
so. We have been
Focused on ensuring that
the architecture from
the beginning is secure and stays
secure as we bring in new tools
and use these tools for
development purposes.
So that's where
the
like the primary reliance on a
hardened cloud like
AWS's
is uh
pretty important for us and
the fact that poolside we are able to
completely.
Integrate that and also
maintain the air gap system without any
access to external
systems, um,
that is very key for us and
also it allows full control
from
the end to end
debugging, testing code development
and all the way to.
Like full loop validation of the systems
that we really
integrate uh with other
data systems that are private
and that makes
for the case that the in
addition to the other
options that we had, it was very important to
ensure that the models that we use
to request and
serve endpoints
are not outside of the systems.
That we control. So that
was another key
important aspect for us
and in terms of
the existing
hardened configuration,
including the ts standards and guidelines
that
uh exist in our existing systems,
whenever there's a new tool we need to
ensure that uh that is also
taken care all the way from the OS
application layer.
To the network ingress egress
and the fact that the compliance
can be maintained was another key
um important factor for us.
And this goes with PIPS 140
in terms of uh ensuring any cryptographic
implications or also
FIPS compliant and
that's one of the key aspects.
And I'll walk through some of
the use cases we've been
um exploring with Poolside uh
which stresses on
the importance of having the sovereignty
over like the data
and also the IP that a
company like us would kind of use
and.
So, on the documentation side, it
is very typical for us,
or in our use cases to enrich
existing code bases
with more
documentations, not just within the
code, but also pulling data from other
systems like where we define tasks
and system-level descriptions.
But being confident that we
can pull in those into the context of the agents
and the models.
While ensuring that we don't
send data to a remote
endpoint
uh across the network is
pretty
base minimum level requirement from our side
and so we've been
happy with that uh capability
that we are able to.
Use internal data
because we know that the the model is
being served on the closed
air gap environment
and with that
not only the documentation
is much more enhanced with the
code level details but also with system
level details that it
then reinforces the context
that are more important and relevant for the systems
that are being developed
and likewise same goes for
the. Test generation pipeline
previously you had to depend on unit level
tests that are very siloed
given a code context, but.
The fact that we can now extend it
to internal end to end test
but also require system level understanding
uh is a key enablement
for us
and also
like one of the examples we saw from the
code uh like code refactoring agents
with Ada's full porto so
there are
systems, not just legacy for legacy.
purposes, but they are really
hardened and tested well for
really. Spacecraft
grade uh requirements and
the fact that now we can leverage these advanced
agents to be able to port over
with like the same levels of reliability
has been a key enabler.
So with that I'll
pass it back to
Corey. Yeah, thank you
so much, Praveen.
And uh just, just to wrap this up here,
um, uh, uh.
Poolside, you know, it, it, it, as we learned
in that first section, we're frontier Model lab
building secure enterprise AI systems
that can be deployed anywhere. Uh,
we build these AI models and the AI orchestration
platform. This is all from scratch,
uh, that is designed to run entirely with your
within your own infrastructure, even in an air gapped,
uh, scenario.
As an organization,
you, you with Poolside, you have an isolated AI
stack that you can build on for the future,
uh, and you'll receive, you know, the latest model
updates as we, as we publish them. We are a frontier lab.
We're continually doing more and more model training, building
better and better and more capable models, um,
as we have those, you will get them, uh,
but not risk the data egress or,
you know, losing core IP of your business. And
as, uh, Eva pointed out, we have a customer
approach built
around if needed for deployed research engineers,
uh, that we can power this software stack with.
Uh, our 4 deployed research engineers embed
with your team, uh, and help you solve even
the most mission critical,
complex, uh, challenges with agents. Give us the
most complex, hardest, uh, hardest
problem to solve as this agent orchestration
pipeline.
All this again is, you know, behind your firewall,
so it's this mix of
software and, uh, and, and
teams and people and research engineers, uh,
to help, you know, your organization regardless of
where that organization, in this case for
this talk develops software or
in maybe another business process,
uh, has a business outcome they want to
enable with uh
uh AI to create and become this
agentic uh organization, this agentic enterprise.
So if you'd like to dig in more, um, I believe
we actually have some extra time, uh, built
into this talk, and we can take some questions off
stage, um, or you can come visit our booth
out in the expo hall again,
uh, 802, come get some poolside swag and
talk to us about how we can help out your organization.
Thanks.